[Music]
jen is in phoenix hi jen welcome to the
ramsey show
hi thank you so much for taking my call
um i was in a position last year to
purchase a home but um unfortunately the
line of work that i was in um i have a
child who
you know is on the spectrum and the job
that i was working with a child
protective
capacity and they wanted evenings
holidays and weekends so i had to leave
that job and in the three months that it
took me to get another job
um it made better sense to sell my home
and to rent it because i didn't have the
cash flow and i was wondering um i got
the money out of my home
i'm
i'm really sad that i had to sell it
anyways but i'm wondering i'm
just getting apprehensive about if i'll
ever be able to enter the market again
and exactly what i should do with the
money that i have saved because it's i
have it all sitting there when you take
it back in the market when things are a
little bit more stable
what's unstable
well it's stable in the sense that i
have a job now that that i can be a
mother and be you know work for so are
they are they is your life stable now
oh it is it just took me i knew that i
would i'm employable and very employable
but it just took a couple months to
delete the budget you said you were
going to wait until things were more
stable but it sounds like they are
stable
well yes they are
they are i'm sorry i'm nervous what is
keeping you from going and buying a
house then
i well i just came out i just sold my
home and i just wanted to i don't know
the with interest rates up and and
everything i don't know if i can
actually afford um
i just don't know what i can afford i
don't know what would be smart i know
waiting probably isn't
but i'm i just
i just want to make sure that i can
afford it so you're making a whole lot
of assumptions
about everything being horrible and you
don't even know the details
no i need to sit down and i do apologize
i'm i just no i'm not i'm not calling
you out i just hear a lot of anxiety in
your voice
i i i even wonder
my home represented more than 40 of my
take home and i thought about um renting
the one that i had no you did the right
thing
you did the right thing you were you
were trying listen here's what you chose
here's what i heard
you chose taking care of your kid
yeah which makes you like the best mom
in the world
in the world the the
by owning a home does not make you the
best mom memorial
sure you can get into the house there's
freaking house on every corner you just
got one kid though
yeah that's true you made the right
choice
thank you you were in the situation you
were in with the information you had you
made the best decision you could make at
the time right
no i did thank you so quit beating
yourself up you're an awesome mom
okay
let's breathe in and let's put all of
that in the rear view mirror
now let's look out the windshield
okay okay
you now have a stable situation where
you can take care of the kid how much
money you got in the bank from the sale
of the house
about 70 000. okay
nothing's on fire
you don't have to rush out and do
anything
but let's just begin the process
of learning about what it is you can
afford
at twenty five percent of your take-home
pay with seventy thousand dollars down
on a fifteen year fixed rate mortgage
and begin to look at those types of
houses
and go i don't really want to buy one of
those i think i'll save a little while
before and add some to the 70 before i
do that that's okay
but we're not going to sit around and
watch the news
and by the way interest rates went down
this week
oh
okay i'm just i'm traumatizing myself by
saying that exactly yeah you're
catastrophizing
so and that's okay i mean you've been
through you've been through a lot you
had a lot of stress
and i what i'm what i want you to do is
is
gain some peace from
where you're sitting today and and from
the fact that you did make good
decisions
and now let's just ease back towards the
right direction of home ownership again
and uh but we don't have to thrash
around and say oh we can't do it because
the interest rates are oh we better do
it because we'll never get in if we
don't rush over there and get something
right now and just oh
calm
sorry
and let's just steady
yeah facts are your friends i love that
getting getting your plan together
figuring out what you can actually
afford laying everything out on paper on
purpose so that you can see clearly not
just feel that anxiety and just live
there but i'm with dave you're a great
mom you made the right decision for your
family um one question i have is are you
still in the same job or do you still
have a pretty unstable schedule with
evenings and weekends and
nights no i'm looking for i'm in the
same capacity but i'm in a job that
doesn't require me i can actually work
from home in this job that the other job
i had to be like out in
how much do you mean
about 50.
okay
how long are you
i'm in my late 40s okay how's your baby
she's 12 this year okay good good well i
think that's even a breathing point
you're probably feeling some of the fear
from just the last time you owned a home
and you were in that situation where
things felt out of control and you know
you're working the weekends it's
difficult balancing a family and even
breathing and letting that go and just
kind of refocusing as you think about
buying another house you know and just
letting go of some of that stress and
difficulty from the last time this is a
new situation you're in a totally
different position
your baby's taken care of you're in a
good spot to move forward yeah just
because the last guy you dated as a jerk
doesn't mean the next one has to be
i've been doing it in years no no i'm
talking about the last house didn't work
because you bought too much house and it
was an unstable job situation so the new
house
doesn't have to be a jerk it can be okay
right
he said definitely and i guess what i'm
wondering is i don't i don't mind
leaving i mean my job i can't whether i
like it or not they're putting 12 away
from me of my salary and i think they're
matching it so i can't even touch that
so i'm whether i want to save retirement
right now i'm saving it away all right
well you're moving in the right
direction you got everything going so
what i would tell you to do is if you're
debt free let's hold that 70 000 and
begin to add to it get in touch with uh
one of the uh endorsed local providers
one of the ramsey trusted real estate
agents in your area
sit down with them and say
listen i'm a little scared and freaked
out because
i bought too much house last time and it
scared me and i had to get out of it i
don't want to do that again and so i
need to get start gathering information
to help me make a calm
wise decision teach me
help me show me the market and let's
begin to work our way through that and
they will gently gradually slowly
show you and you you'll get your
confidence based on the new knowledge
you start gathering from this elp with
the heart of a teacher well i think
that's good for anyone sitting on the
sidelines of the real estate market
right now because the reality is
every day there's a new news article out
that sounds scary and there's a million
different opinions and there's a lot of
fear you know you have a very legitimate
situation where you know you had some
family things and too much house that
caused fear now but there's a lot of
people feeling fear for a lot of reasons
so sit down figure out the facts talk to
a professional who knows what they're
doing and can bring peace yeah
when you're feeling all hyped up folks
the lonely talks about this all the time
facts are your friends
no one makes good decisions
when they're afraid
greedy or drunk
this is the ramsey show